hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast manufacturing and
characterization of therapeutic exosomes
presented by Travis Janet s PhD we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Milton E biotech Milton e
biotech is a global provider of products
and services that advanced biomedical
research and cellular therapy the
company's innovative tools support
research at every level from basic
research to translational research to
clinical application this integrated
portfolio enables scientists and
clinicians to obtain analyze and utilize
the cell Milton E biotechs technologies
covered techniques of sample preparation
cell isolation cell sorting flow
cytometry cell culture molecular
analysis and preclinical imaging there
more than 25 years of expertise expands
research areas including new knowledge e
stem cell biology neuroscience and
cancer and clinical research areas like
hematology graft engineering and a
phoresis the company also offers
comprehensive scientific support
consultation and expert training to
learn more about Milton e biotech visit
w-w-w MLT biotech com I am Judy O'Rourke
of lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's events this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CC button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
to anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
you will be viewing a presentation in
the slide window to launch the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right and finally if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you
I'd like to introduce dr. Ann Tess who
is the head of analytical development at
Capricorn therapeutics incorporated
doctorate and Tess's PhD work
investigated the mechanisms of RNA
editing directed by small RNA guides in
conjunction with the RNA polymerase
machinery he expanded his training in
RNA synthesis and transcription
regulation with a postdoctoral
fellowship at Stanford University in his
first industry appointment at Belgian
doctor and tests managed the gene
expression group responsible for
characterizing the transcriptome changes
in knockout mouse models he later worked
for system Biosciences where he was a
principal investigator an independent
small business innovation research
grants and later senior director of
product development in 2016 he joined
the faculty at the Cedars Sinai Heart
Institute as an associate professor and
became the head of analytical
development for Capricorn sarap uux his
current research involves the
characterization and development of
therapeutic exosomes for a variety of
disease applications dr. and Tessa's
complete bio is found on the labyrinth
website please join me in welcoming dr.
and Tess I will now turn the
presentation over to him hello this is
true
welcome everybody to the webinar and
thank you for joining us so today we're
going to talk about how do we
manufacture characterize and KFC
therapeutic exosomes for use in
preclinical studies so I work on faculty
member at cedars-sinai and I work for a
innovative Council for therapeutics
located here in Los Angeles
Capricorn repute --ax is a publicly
traded company so I have my standard
forward-looking statements here that you
can review at a later time and so for
today's presentation don't worry if you
tuned in and you hadn't heard the word
exosome before I'm gonna tell you what
they are and and how they work and then
we'll review the how to manufacture them
from their host cell here and then after
we manufacture them how do we
characterize them and QC them how do we
profile the RNA cargo and then do some
surface protein phenotyping using flow
cytometry and lastly I will describe and
show you some data of some preclinical
work we've done with these therapeutic
exercise so let's start off with what
our exercise now if you might notice the
title of this slide shows background on
eating so V's are more general term for
extracellular vesicles so vesicles can
be derived from by budding directly from
the outer membrane shown here and these
are called micro vesicles or even called
sometimes active zones now the term
exosome here means that it's derived
from the interior of the cell from the
late endosome and then maturing in the
multi particular body shown here now
once this mbb collects
hundreds of these exosomes if/then is
trafficked to the surface of the cell
and these exosomes are then released in
a burst from the cells so the signaling
that takes place in this whole process
is just now being understood and it's
pretty exciting to figure out how these
vesicles these small vesicles are
assembled how are some are targeted for
degradation and how some of them are
meant for release for signaling so
there's size of these smaller vesicles
range they say you know typically 30 to
100 sometimes 150 nanometers in diameter
there are some common surface markers
shown here grabs 5b or some other
surface proteins CD 63 CD 9 or CD a you
want I like showing this image after the
cartoon so you kind of get an idea of
how these things are assembled but
here's some really dramatic images from
this publication shown here from 2011
and here if you look this is a multi
particular body encircled in yellow and
then I've highlighted in this red box
and and blew it up in size that you can
see these individual double membrane
vesicles these are called exercise so in
step one the exosomes are present and
multi particular bodies and then they
assembled like I said sometimes even
hundreds of them coming into here and
I'm showing in white arrows and also
here in this red arrow here's here's a
exosome being brought into the MV B for
assembly and processing the next step
and in their maturation is
that they proceed to the surface of the
cell and then like we talked about in
the graphic then they are released as a
burst of vesicles what are some of the
features of extracellular vesicles and
exercise well I mentioned that they're
that they're small 60 to 150 diameters
in size their proteins can vary
depending upon the parent cell that
built them the common markers shown here
are hsp70 CD 63 CD 9c d 81 now what also
sets exosomes apart from other vesicles
is that they carry a very diverse types
of RNA cargo messenger RNA micro RNA
long non-coding RNA called lengthening
or other non-coding RNA species NC RNA
what do these vesicles do well what we
do know is that they modulate the immune
system so initially what's believed to
happen in tumor cells in the in the body
so they produced a lot of e DS that
suppress the immune systems or immune
system is not going to clear out the
tumor cells so that's a bad thing but
there are other immunomodulatory
features that we can use these vesicles
to then hopefully treat inflammatory
disorders and we'll talk about that
towards the end of this presentation
exosomes can affect cell proliferation
and they're also involved in
communication within your neuronal
system here at cedars-sinai at the Heart
Institute we're interested in treating
heart failure so heart failure can can
mean anything from the heart attack to
an arrhythmia to
to other diseases of the heart an insta
the major public health challenge within
the world and sex 5.7 million Americans
every year half of the people who do
develop heart failure will die within
five years of their diagnosis
and it's been estimated that this
disease across the nation an estimated
30 point seven billion dollars every
year for treatment and hospital problems
now a lot of our tissues in our body do
have the ability to regenerate after
injury you know the major example of
that is your skin if you get a scrape or
a cut you know in a few days it seals
itself over and installs themselves and
it looks either new or almost new
however human hearts have very limited
to no regenerative capacity so there is
injury to the myocardium there really
isn't any way to fix that so with the
hearts with myocardium does is it
infiltrates a bunch of these just like
surface cells or fibroblast and they're
very stiff cells so they don't actually
operate like myocardial anymore today
there are really no treatments that can
reverse heart failure which is a
progressive condition after the initial
injury so now that we know that there's
a great application for these
therapeutic exercise how do we
manufacture these so I'm going to show
you kind of an outline of how we do it
and so you can understand a little bit
more about our process so the first step
is Capricorn receives a call from a
donor facility if someone has
asked on and they offered to donate
their heart for for research and
therapeutic development then we got that
follow me though and we obtained the
organ from the donor and then we create
these X plants which are kind of pieces
of tissue from this heart from different
areas of the donated heart we didn't
culture them in these flats and let them
grow out a little bit further and then
we create what's called a master cell
bank and this is where after we grow
them to substantial numbers we then can
aliquot or put them in different files
and store them at minus 80 or in liquid
nitrogen or for later use once we're
ready to then manufacture some exosomes
we take the master cell bank and then we
put them in a certain special media to
create whatever we call cardio spheres
so these this is a collection or globe
of cells that then are stem like in
nature we expand them again in culture
and then we after we replate them here
they form a layer on these flasks and
this now is your allergenic CDC or cell
product that can be used either in the
clinic or in this talk further processed
to grow confluence cdc's which means
just they fill up the whole flask and
then we harvest the culture medium
here's one indicated by CM so in this
culture medium will be all of the
episomes that these cells have secreted
we then isolate them and then we
characterize them and then we freeze
them in individual vials for use in
preclinical study
so here is a more detailed look at the
protection of the EVs I just showed you
a kind of an overall scheme so after a
passage five confluent CDC culture is
obtained in these flasks we then remove
the meeting wash it a couple of times
and now this an important step is we
then culture the cells for 48 hours for
15 days in serum-free medium now the
reason why that's important is because
when you typically culture cells you put
in fetal bovine serum which is it's
called FBS and this helps support the
cells grow now the problem with that is
that there are just tons and tons of cow
exosomes present nepia so we need to
culture ourselves in serum-free medium
so that we're not adding in character
cells but we're just going to collect
the human exosomes made by the cdc cell
so the next step is that we pass the
culture medium through a point four five
micron filter this is for sterilization
and then we store it at minus-8 and then
when we're ready to make the e DS we've
been using a 100 kilo dalton molecular
weight cut off MW co ultra filtration by
centrifugation in this unit has a since
she has a column and a membrane and it
and what when you spin it everything
that is smaller than 100 KD ends up here
in the bottom now an exosome although
it's maybe a hundred nanometers in size
it's in more in like the giga dolphin
size so it will not pass through so it
will stay up here in the top and then
you can just remove all the things that
this filter through and when you're
ready you just flip the column over spin
it again and then here you end up with
your concentrated
culture medium containing the eating
right so we've got our CDC selves we've
grown them up we've conditioned them
them serum-free medium we've collected
the media and we concentrated it or
exome isolation now how do we test what
our recovery was in this next portion of
my talk I'm going to talk about Eevee or
extracellular vesicle characterization
the topics I'm going to cover are some
of the standards and the X ISM industry
of particle concentration and sizing
them by using either nano site profiling
and I'm going to introduce a new
platform that I've been using recently
by a little startup company in Boston
called nano view and they use a method
where they use inter federal metrics
which essentially is looking at how
light passes through vesicles on a slide
we also use a standard electron e/m
microscopy we'll look at the protein
composition by Western blots and also
close cytometry there's other ways to
characterize the exosomes using
biochemical acids so exosomes carry this
enzyme acetylcholinesterase which is an
easy enzyme to measure using a cola
metric assay so the first method that I
mentioned is called nano site and it's a
dynamic light gathering technology
here's a picture of what the instrument
looks like it has a computer and then
here's the nano site itself your sample
gets put in through this syringe pump
and it ends up going into the instrument
so what the instrument uses is a
microscope here and then this is the
sample chamber that you just build
you're exosome sample so it's in liquid
and is there free to move about the
chamber and then the key next part is
that there's a laser that comes through
your sample chamber here and every time
a particle passes through the laser it
produces a signal so exosomes are just
too small to see by standard microscopy
so this is this uses a technology called
dynamic light scattering every time an
exome passes through the laser you know
what it forms this little speck here now
based upon the number of specs that the
software sees and also how fast it moves
in the chamber you it then can tell you
the size and the concentration of the
exosomes in your sample so here's an
example up here in a of three different
donors where we took X plants culture
the cdc's and then harvested their
exercise and what the Nano saw report
gives you is a size distribution shown
you here by this this curve and this
number here tells you the majority of
your vesicles are what size and I think
if the whole fuzzy here we can see it's
about 73 nanometers in diameter for this
donor eighty-one for this donor donor
and I think 88 here so there is some
variability between x's on crepes but
typically what we look for is something
that's less than 120 or 150 nanometers
that's near typical exosome or Eevee
size distribution now it also reports
the number of particles per mil that it
was able to count and so these are two
important pieces of information for
going forward so that you know first
that the size distributions for that
and also now you know how many exosomes
per mil are actually in your sample we
sometimes go further and characterize
them by electron microscopy this first
set of panels here this is negative
stain e/m here and so you can see the
vesicles shown here and kind of this
glowing sphere and you can size them and
if you look at essentially what their
size looks like when they're dried down
there about I don't know maybe about 50
or 60 nanometers and the same thing by
cryo iam cryo means that your sample is
frozen and then it keeps the membrane
intact and you can visualize them here
but in both of these analysis you see
that the in the dried form of these
exons are actually a little smaller than
100 nanometers to further characterize
these vesicles exosome of these isolated
there are some classic markers that you
can use so you make a protein lysate
from your desk when you're in the money
Western block and here I'm showing you
samples from the producer cells the CDC
cells or their exosomes which here I'm
calling cap 2003
so CD 81 is expressed in both the cells
and in the exosomes we isolated there's
another protein called peri Ostin that
seems to be highly enriched in exosomes
versus their cells and then finally to
show that you didn't have any cellular
contamination this is a an antibody for
a protein called calnexin
which is present in the ER of your cell
and should not be present in your
exercise so you see here it is present
in the producer cells but it is not
present in your isolated episode so this
tells you that you've got a really clean
prep and enriched for the episomes
from your
down ourselves and then the last thing
is that you can characterize them for
acetylcholinesterase activity shown here
and there are some standard asset kits
for doing this it's a polar metric assay
and you can read this on your standard
plate reader in the lab and you see that
there is some variability from donor to
donor based on the acetylcholine
esterase activity but they don't vary
more than about 2 fold between each
other so this is a more comprehensive
panel of things that we that we do to
characterize our exercise now we're not
going to do this on every exosome prep
clearly but when we establish our method
of how we isolate these vesicles and we
we decide upon a defined protocol then
we do all of these assays to ensure that
we're getting what we think we're
getting from the culture medium of the
CDC producer south ok so I've shown you
nano site and we did some western blots
physical Mysteries assays and some PM
now there's this other new platform that
I've been working with the founders with
called nano human there they're in
Boston so this is a chip sensor where
you have antibodies that are that are
directly printed onto this chip and then
you put your your exosome sample onto
this chip shown here and then the
antibodies will pick it up or skirts
have it stick to the chip and then you
scan the chip so you can have a number
of different antibodies on this chip you
put your X's on sample over and then by
this this business does this realization
software a method
you can actually count and see the
individual exosomes on this chip using a
microscope they developed automated
software that allows you to figure out
size distribution similar to a nanosec
dose and also how many particles for a
given antibody spot that it could detect
so here's some data that we got from our
CDC exosomes
when we found them on a CD 63 sensor
chip shown here you see that we get
across these six different sources that
we get a distribution very similar to
what we see in nano sight however their
peak size is more like in the 50 to 60
range now that is more consistent with
the EMS that's where they're dried down
and you see them exactly as they are
from their from their membrane kind of
encircling them so that is CD 63 we did
the same thing for CD 81 capture
antibody and again you see that the peak
size of the particles is still somewhere
around no 60 to 65 and here i estimate
50 to 75 so this size range seems much
similar to what we saw using scanning PM
now another aspect to this platform is
once you do have the exosomes captured
on this chip sensor you can dry it down
and then shadow them to look at them
with scanning vm so that little snapshot
is shown here and so these are
individual exosomes bound by an antibody
on this sensor chip and you can figure
out their size here
which seems to match up quite nicely to
what we saw in these scanning books so
which brings us to the question of well
how come it's so different in this size
diameter when you look at the set
stomach either by nano site or by nano
well here I've done a drawing to try to
explain how the two different
technologies see an individual exercise
so in our nano site studies if you
noticed sometimes they had a diameter of
around 100 to 120 nanometers now when
this technology dynamic light scattering
looks at a particle it's seeing
everything so even what's inside here
and also it's protein shell if you will
so a lot of proteins that are bound to
an individual XSL so it actually is
looking at the diameter coming from here
to here so that will be much larger than
the individual particle itself between
here shonan's
with brown gold fear so when you look at
exosomes by scanning e/m or with nano
view you are just seeing the diameter of
these vesicles from here to here and if
you notice then the data I showed you
both with DM so cryo-em was 90 the Nano
View chip said it was around 70 and then
the scanning a.m. was around 65 so this
is probably closer to what you'll see
from the within the inside interior of
the exposome and not necessarily looking
at the protein show
okay so we physically characterized or
exosomes now and what makes exosomes
pretty exciting what actually got me
interested in them originally is that
these vessels are shuttles of RNA so RNA
is packaged into these vesicles the
vesicles are secreted and then when they
bind to a another target cell they can
deliver this RNA and this RNA can have
major influences on the phenotype of its
recipient cell so how do you know what
RNAs are important in in your exercise
of interest nowadays the first step is
that you do RNA C and we've chosen to
use the Illumina platform because it's
highly sensitive and we don't need a
whole lot of RNA in order to get a lot
of information shown here are some
doughnut rings of types of RNAs
present in either CDC exosomes mizenko
mole stem cell exosomes or called MCS
that are either cultured by 15 days or
MSC's cultured after 48 hours of hypoxia
and when we look at all the RNA
sequences we calibrate it to an
endogenous reference it in for these
exosomes we use mirror 22 now for the
exosomes you're studying you might need
to find a suitable reference marker that
is more consistent for your particular
episode now the ones that we study Mir
22 serves as a pretty good reference
marker and when we filter these through
a heat map generator what you see is
that all of the CDC derived exosomes
cluster together shown here in this red
box and that the MSC's will stratify and
form their own family shown here so
these are very different
CDC exosomes are very different from
PSSs so we look at micro nays messenger
rna's link rnas and also other
non-coding rnas what we discovered just
recently and published this year is a
very interesting RNA as present and cbc
exosomes called why RNA and when we
treat our clinic preclinical studies of
heart attack and mice what we found out
is that the episome that have more of
the why RNA tending to improve what's
called the ejection fraction of injured
heart tissue so the difference between
non potent and potent exosomes
really depends on the amount of why RNA
that it has so if you've got more
accounts of why RNA it tends to be more
potent and helps repair hearts after a
myocardial infarction when we look at
here the number of RNA seek needs from
50,000 up to 450,000 reads and just
focus on this Y on a fragment what we
observed is that in fiberglass exosomes
we call them NH DF which are normal
human dermal fiberglass and then three
different lines of CDC's derived from
donors that tended to be non potent in
our ejection fraction assay so they're
not able to help heal the hearts but now
these other donors shown here here and
here that had the higher amount of Y RNA
to be much more potent in healing hearts
after myocardial infarction so what we
conclude from this is that this lie on a
fragment seems to be important in
signaling damaged tissue okay so that's
RNA now what about the surfaces of these
of these exosomes
what's important about them on their
surfaces for them to be taken up by
target cells and also these these
surface proteins themselves can be
signaling molecules so to do this in
kind of a high-throughput fashion and
you're just interested on the surface
signaling proteins we turn to using a
really neat kit produced by Milton II
called the max Plex exosome kit and this
allows you to profile numerous surface
proteins simultaneously in one assay and
the clever technology here is that each
bead that has an individual antibody on
it is also indexed so each individual
beat will have its own combination here
as a showing an example of a ABC
fluorescence now when this is put into
the the max flex flow cytometry
each bead will flow to a certain region
within the load cell and that's based on
this index in each one of these little
areas that it flows to is what it means
is that there's a particular antibody
for each beat so this bead has a certain
markers this one has a certain marker
and then the flow cytometry looks at the
fluorescence in each one of these areas
and then that gives you your
quantification of how many exosomes
in your sample have that particular
surface protein
so here's shown down here and say beat a
that is for OCD 105 and when it finds
exosomes then it will count how many
exosomes or CB 105 positive or CD 63
positive or a CD 49 positive something
like that so that's the introduction to
basics of how this kit works and then
you can look at the map for each spot
and what it corresponds to I've shown
this here you can find all this
information on the Milton a website but
you can profile all of these different
surface antigens simultaneously because
these beads will migrate to a different
area within the flow cell so I've
highlighted a few here that I wanted to
keep an eye on
so CD 105 is endothelial markers that we
know are present on our CDC exosome so I
was looking to see if this kit would you
know validate that and verify that and
of course we also know cd8 1 is presence
on our episomes
CD 63 for sure as present and then we
have just a little bit amount of CD 9
and our exercise this we know by doing
western blots so - these are just some
markers I kind of kept in the back of my
mind
well after we did these assays so here's
the maxiflex 8 color Mac squat
instrument shown here it's a really
really cool device you load your sample
right here and then it does the flow
analysis and over here on the right is
an actual screenshot of what you see for
the each individual B that gets migrates
to its own area corresponding
to a specific surface market and this is
what it looks like and you can see this
one is pretty bright here whereas maybe
this one here isn't so effective and
then the software quantitate Sall that
and gives you a full report so this is
kind of hard to see but I wanted to give
you a snapshot of a number of different
TBC donors here some MSC exosomes here
and the colouring corresponds to if it's
red it's it was highly detected and if
it's dark green it was a lot lower and
wanted to highlight here's C D 9 was
detected and then C D 63 was detected
and I actually used that as my
calibration marker so everything is
calibrated to the amount of C D 63
exosomes detected you see that this is
all these values will be one for all the
samples and then once that calibration
was done I noted a few markers of
interest for my CDC Excel that I was
hoping to speak that would be C D 105
which is great I also noted cd40 90 was
interesting and then some of these
others here C D 48 621 be tended to be
more highly expressed here and versus
the CMS exas M here so stay pleased with
the performance and the quantitative
capabilities of this asset here's a
condensed version of the very colorful
table I just showed you and I generated
the heat and so the types of exosomes
that we ran through these assays the
high abundant ones are shown red and the
low abundant ones are shown in blue and
when you do a cluster hierarchical
cluster analysis
I was happy to see that all our potent
CDC exosomes clustered here the
fibroblast exosomes just by themselves
here
the NSE exosomes ended up being their
own group and here is a non potent cdc
exosome shown here you see how it
clusters differently from all the other
potent ones here and because I have
these samples I also had some IPS C
cells that were differentiated into
cardiomyocytes and we collected their
exosomes just to see how they would
stack up and that's shown here called
ICM and do discarding myocytes and you
see that they are actually quite
different from our from our CDC exercise
shown here okay so we looked at the RNA
now we've looked at the surface
phenotype let's begin developing these
for clinical or even preclinical
applications and regenerative medicine
so as mentioned earlier our cardio
sphere derived cells or CDC's generate
and secrete these therapeutic exosomes
here us and many others have published
and shown that these exosomes modulate
the immune system they actually calm it
down they're protective for cells or we
call it a fighter protection or their
anti-apoptotic in death so they're
anti-death they help sell our myocardium
grow new blood vessels of angio genic
they also reduce this fibrosis that I
mentioned earlier when the heart tries
to heal itself rapidly this is like a
non functional duct tape in your heart
and these exosomes are anti v and then
finally they have a regenerative
capability which means that they
stimulate growth of new myocardium after
tissue damage and this is best shown
here this is a report from 2014 by my
colleague here on the Ibrahim and this
is a cross-section of heart actors
undergone a myocardial infarction and
here is the left ventricle which which
usually incurs the most damage and you
see how it's very very thin here after
this infarction heart attack and the
blue color stains for the fibroblasts or
the fibrotic cell so in the control or
untreated you see there's very little
repair going on at all when we use
dermal fibroblasts n hdf exosome you get
a little bit of repair but again this is
just because of the blue color
it's just fibrotic cells so it's not
going to contract and function very well
however when you treat the hearts with
the cdc exosomes after infarction you
see much greater wall built here lower
fibrotic tissue and some new myocardium
being constructed here so we'd like to
say our CDC episode 10 - keel hearts
after a heart attack more data from
those studies here I'm going to show you
the left ventricular ejection fraction
and this measures the blood pumping
ability of a heart and so after our
attack and then days after the
myocardial infarction we measure the
ejection fraction using echocardiography
and we're looking directly at the heart
using soundwaves and in the vehicle
which is our PBS carrier liquid was the
same there's the vehicle
and here's the bugger blast exosomes you
see that after the myocardial infarction
the ejection fraction did not improve
through 30 days of athletic however in
the animals the group traded with the
CBC exosomes you see you get a nice
improvement even after 15 days and it
continues up through the month of the
assay so that's showing the therapeutic
capability of these xsm and how do we
know their exes well something I maybe I
forgot to mention but there's a there's
a drug that you can treat yourselves
with called GW for eight six nine and
this inhibits the cells from secreting
exercise so it's a useful tool to just
confirm and show that you're actually
looking at exercise so we either had our
CDC's treated with the drug carrier here
DMSO or we treat our CDC's with GW for
eight six nine and then we cultured them
for 15 days collected the exosomes
and then used those exosomes and this
myocardial infarction ethic so in the
CDC cells treated with the drug and then
we collected the exosomes you see that
there really was no improvement of the
ejection fraction in our 30-day si but
as seen before in the CDC cells treated
with a foot with a control that we did
get improvement after 15 days and even
enhancement after 30 days of the
function of these hearts after a heart
attack with it so we know that our CDC
exosomes can get into cardiomyocytes
heart cells when other types of cells
will will take out these exosomes
so we're interested in looking at what's
called the bio distribution or will
these cdc exosomes only be taken up by
heart cells or our other cells willing
to take these out and maybe you know be
bet beneficial and therapeutically so
the types of cells intestines with our
cdc exosomes are our fibroblasts again
here now we've also tested corneal cells
from the I who looked at T cells their
jerk at T cells and monocytes in th p1
cells here now so you add your first you
label your exosomes with this
fluorescent dye called the ID then you
add them to these different types of
cells and then do flow cytometry on the
cell to see what the fluorescent uptick
was so from one hour after you add the
exosomes
four hours and then overnight so the
amount of uptake now is measured by the
fluorescent signal that these cells have
acquired from the X and what we were
happy to see is that our CD are labeled
CBC episomes
in up to four hours and even overnight
shown here in blue these are the cells
that have taken up the exosomes or CBC
it's done you see that fiberglass cornea
cells t-cells and monocytes all are
capable of taking up our therapeutic
exercise so what other types of clinical
areas might we be able to use these for
to have some sort of clinical benefit
I've already shown you the heart
regeneration athletes and things we've
done but we also wanted to try now that
we know that I sell
take them up and also immune cells so
there is a eye disease called
GVHD or called graft-versus-host disease
and this is when people receive a bone
marrow transplant because they lost
capable of bone marrow and they
essentially have a new immune system and
one of the first indications of this
rejection or this immune dysfunction is
that patients eyes begin to be very
painful burning irritation photophobia
which means you're sensitive to light
you pain dryness and there's no approved
therapies other than eyedrops to help
and those don't really do much for you a
little bit about the this disease 8500
bone-marrow transplants are performed in
the US every year
about 40% of these patients end up
having this ocular of those
graft-versus-host disease and every year
there's about 3400 new cases every year
so it's a small orphan disease but if
they're like I said there are no
treatments for this and we thought since
they're CDC exosomes
seem to have benefit in damage chart
when they work for damaged eyes so the
next step is we wanted to see well as we
wanted to treat the eyes how do we get
our exosomes to the right area
so we tried two different ways one is by
topical so kind of like what you would
do I drops just drop it on your eye or
we would inject them so you'd have a
syringe with your ex or something in a
syringe and you would inject it into
this so tons of table space right here
and so we delivered them using either
topical
shown here in green or by injection blue
and when I say healthy or versus alkali
burn this is a this is how we do our I
repair model to actually introduce a
burn and cornea for a short amount just
using sodium hydroxide then you remove
it and then you look at the healing
afterwards and we'll get to that so here
we just wanted to see if our CBC
exosomes would go to the right area and
what we found if we only injected the
right eye of the test mice that is where
most of the exosomes were found and
interestingly we had some that did
travel to the left eye and we had from
the rejection they ended up in the liver
but not by the eye drop method another
curious aspect to this is that our
exosomes did traffic to the heart so to
me and I think that's really interesting
that even either and if they're injected
or just applied to the eye using eye
drops they seem to have some sort of
homing beacon that they do end up coming
back to the heart which is really
interesting it's a process of exploring
immune cells and the spleen and in the
lungs will pick up the exosomes it's
only if you inject them but not by
topical same thing the gonads and kidney
and we did not see any significant
trafficking or bio distribution of our
exosomes to the brain
so in our alkali burn GVHD models there
are two different assays that we look
for one the first one is called a
clinical score and this looks for shown
here summarized is the opacification
which means is the cornea getting cloudy
and then we look for new vessels or
neovascularization the area affected if
it's starting to heal and close and some
other parameters for the aqueous flare
and this is where we look on the inside
of the eyes so our treatment groups here
are going to be just our vehicle for our
CDC exosomes applied by topical this is
I drop or injected into the subconscious
subconscious and after going through the
clinical scoring you see that so the
higher the score the worse that they're
doing so here's day day zero which this
is normal high function and appearance
in the vehicle treated group that had
the alkali burn they got to a pretty
high clinical score meaning bad and just
gradually doesn't seem to improve over
time after three weeks but with our
either topical or our injected CDC
exosomes
we saw significant improvement over the
course of time over our three three
weeks evaluation each day we measured
all these clinical endpoints so the CDC
exosome seemed to heal I and this
alkali burn injury model and then more
specifically we looked at the corneal
injury area and measured it so
the injury staying the same size or is
it starting to heal and get better and
so here the higher the injury area means
that it's not healing at all and in
vehicle group shown here really no
significant shrinking of the injury area
was observed but both with topical and
our injected exosomes we were able to
see repair this eye injury in this mouse
model so let's summarize what we talked
about today I introduced you to car you
sphere drive cell these are from human
organ donors we culture them and then we
make their exosomes of EVs these EVs
have can modulate the immune system they
can keep cells from dying cytoprotective
they help in injured tissue grow new
blood vessels angiogenic they reduce the
amount of this fibrotic storing after
tissue injury and they promote the
growth of new myocardium in our heart
attack mouths so they tend to heal the
hearts of these heart attack mouse
models additionally and what we just
finished is that they also seem to have
clinical benefits and ocular
graft-versus-host disease model and help
heal the eyes we I talked about looking
at the defined service phenotype using
the max s flex path days that was useful
for us because it helps us QC our
quality control our exosomes
that we that we generate from our CDC
cells and we believe that
our CDC episomes really hold great
promise for clinical applications of
either autoimmune or tissue regeneration
in the clinic
so I'd like to acknowledge my colleagues
here at Kappa Cora Kyle Peck Jennifer
Johnson Mosely and Sophie ball Ravens on
that ibrahim and the vp of regenerative
medicine here at camp record luis
rodriguez bravado for all our support
and my guys are at nano view for helping
me explore using their platform for
looking at exosome such george boole and
David Freeman over at nano view we're
really terrific to work with and then
also using the surface phenotype
profiling assays really like to thank
Matt McBryan specifically for helping us
set up the app days and run them and
also do the data analysis he taught me
why and Rebecca Lafond at no penny for
also some other data analysis and hand
Gabel today for organizing this webinar
so I could tell you more about how we
manufacture and characterize our
exosomes for clinical development so
with that I'd like to say thank you for
your attention and time today and we
will entertain some questions
thank you dr. Anne test for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. Anne task please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click on the send button we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is after exosome
isolation how do you store the vesicles
that's a great question so how we do it
now is after
we isolate the exposome we do a particle
count and a surface phenotype and once
they pass our certain metrics for that
as a good preparation we then aliquot
them into individual vials and we cryo
store them either at minus eighty or
liquid nitrogen until we want to use
them now when we are ready to use them
we follow them quickly
37 degree water bath and then apply them
in our assays either in the cell culture
or animal models so ultimately what we'd
like to do and what we're working on
right now is to find out some some good
additives that then we would include in
the formulation so that these exosomes
can be stable maybe even just at the
refrigerator level for six months to a
year so we're making good progress
towards that but for the studies I
showed you here and some other work that
we're doing right now we store them at
minus eighty or liquid nitrogen but
we're making progress into making a
off-the-shelf therapeutic I can be just
stored in the refrigerator what other
types of tissues candy or are being used
to manufacture exercise yeah sure so I
told you about our cardiomyocytes that
we get for next plants from donors and
because we're interested in regenerating
heart tissue so we make our cdc exosomes
however there are number other sources
and I think the most popular that you'll
see in the literature and also being
developed by other companies are those
edible stem cell x plants from either
adipose tissue from people or derived
from their bone marrow and they culture
their MSC's and then similar in similar
fashion to what I described is collect
the culture the condition medium and
then isolate their exosomes and those
exosomes are being tested and developed
for
immune disorders similar to what we're
working on with our CDC exercise how do
you confirm or validate RNA sequences
identified by RNA seek right so in your
exosomes that you are developing for
clinical use or even just trying to
understand them more the method of
choice right now is doing RNA seek now
this will give you a broad view of the
RNA types and relative abundances of
specific types and sequences of RNA and
in order to verify them or validate them
I develop sometimes even novel
quantitative PCR assays so then you
would have your CDC exosomes you would
extract their RNA and make it's called
cDNA or complementary DNA and then use
primers and the polymerase chain
reaction in a quantitative qPCR
instrument to then get a better
quantification of the abundance of that
sequence and to also validate your RNA
seek finding the next give me comment
for you to comment on adipose tissue
bone marrow bone marrow our following
sources to manufacture committees and
their excess own
yeah that's right so there are a number
of even some companies that are using
those tissue sources to generate MSC
exosomes maybe I didn't could you repeat
that again oh sure
adipose tissue bone marrow are common
sources to manufacture MSC and their
apps are phone yes that's correct
yeah those are the common sources
because you can get a lot of cells from
those particular tissues I really like
the nanotube platform how do I contact
them so there's a couple of different
ways you can go online and I think there
are web addresses nano view and ano VI w
nano view calm and I they have a phone
numbers and email addresses there or if
you want maybe you can contact our lab
roots friends and they can I can bridge
that contact if you like send yo them
quite well so we're almost out of time
this will have to be our last question
how long did it take to set up and run
the Milton e exosome max flex passes
yeah good question um so it really
depends upon how many different X's on
samples you want to set up but they do
have a way that you can use a 96-well
filter plate to do if you wanted to you
know 96 different samples we typically
would use half the plate so you know 40
or 45 different exosome samples
processed at a time and really the the
prep and the binding takes just a couple
hours that say two hours or so and then
you wash and then you Aleut the exosomes
that are now bound to these beads and
the the low analysis takes about an hour
so start to finish I you know you can do
in half a day which is really great
because then you end up with
profiles of your 40 different exes own
samples all within an afternoon so it's
very streamlined I would like to once
again to say doctor and have for his
presentation do you have any final
comments no I think if you're interested
in exosomes there's a there's a news
website called exosome and then - RNA
dot-com
you can track news articles that talk
about you know basic research of
exosomes as well as clinical development
and maybe you could check that out but I
think it's an exciting time to be in
working on these exosomes and finding
out more about what they're capable of
doing and promoting regenerative
medicine thank you once again I would
also like to thank our sponsor Milton E
biotech for making today's educational
webcast possible this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
Poppa to receive your credits before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through March 6 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay we share that
announcement with your colleagues you
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye
you